>> Laura: AND INCREASINGLY
NUMBER OF SICKENINGLY VIOLENT
CRIMES IS BEING COMMITTED BY
AMERICA'S YOUTH.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
IS IT A PROBLEM, A FAMILY
BREAKDOWN PROBLEM, CULTURAL
PROBLEM OR A CONFIRMATION OF AL
OF THEM?
FOR STORIES, THE CRIMINALITY,
SEEMS TO BE GETTING WORSE.
TO YOU I WOULD TEENS HAVE JUST
BEEN ACCUSED OF KILLING THEIR 6
-YEAR-OLD HIGH SCHOOL SPANISH
TEACHER WITH A BASEBALL BAT.
AND IN MINNEAPOLIS EARLIER THIS
MONTH, A 17 -YEAR-OLD WAS
CHARGED WITH SHOOTING AND
KILLING A MAN WHILE HE SAT IN
HIS CAR AT A GAS STATION.
LAST MONTH A 19 -YEAR-OLD WAS
ARRESTED FOR THE MURDER OF A
NINE -YEAR-OLD GIRL THERE.
BACK IN JANUARY, THE STAR
TRIBUNE EDITORIAL BOARD WARNED
FEAR OF RANDOM VIOLENT CRIME.
ACROSS THE METRO, AUTHORITIES
HAVE BOTH OF THESE CASES TO
TEENS AS YOUNG AS 13.
JOINING ME IS THE FORMER GANG
LEADER, DRUG DEALER, AND, HE IS
ALSO THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF URBAN VENTURES.
JOHN, WHY IS THIS HAPPENING.
YOU ARE BASED IN MINNEAPOLIS.
WE THINK OF MINNESOTA NICE, BUT
WHAT IS DRIVING THE VIOLENCE.
WHEN ALL THE LAWLESSNESS CAME IN
, KIDS GOT A SENSE OF
EMPOWERMENT.
WHERE ARRESTING PEOPLE FOR
CERTAIN THINGS AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE.
AND KIDS HAVE A REBEL SPIRIT IN
ANYWAYS A LOT OF TIME TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
AT ONE TIME YOU KIDS THAT WOULD
KNOCK PEOPLE OUT.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE A BADGE OF
HONOR NOW THESE KIDS, THEY KNOW
THAT THEIR FIRST OFFENSE,
NOTHING WILL HAPPEN TO THEM.
>> HOW MUCH WAS THE SHUT DOWN
DURING COVID ALSO A DRIVER OF
SOME OF THIS WHERE KIDS WERE OU
OF SCHOOL, SOMETIMES FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME AND FORCED TO
NOT SOCIALIZE WITH EACH OTHER.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S AN EXCUSE
BUT THAT COULDN'T HAVE HELPED A
ALREADY PRECARIOUS DYNAMIC.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
KIDS GOT, WHEN THEY SHUT DOWN
HAPPEN, KIDS GOT MORE TIME TO
SPEND WITH KIDS AND SOMETIMES
THAT'S A REALLY BAD SITUATION
WHERE KIDS HAVE TOO MUCH TIME T
SPEND WITH OTHER KIDS, THEY GET
BORED OR WHATEVER AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY TRIED TO THINK OF
SOMETHING TO DO, SOMETHING
EXCITING, SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN DO THAT JUST MAKES THEM SO
COOL AND PART OF THE CROWD.
SO COVID, AND BEING OUT OF
SCHOOL, HURTS TREMENDOUSLY.
>> HOW ABOUT FATHERLESSNESS, HO
DOES THAT AFFECT THIS?
>> FATHER ABSENCE I THINK IS TH
BIGGEST PROBLEM WE HAVE BEEN TH
NATION.
I THINK EVERY FATHER WENT AND
FATHERED THEIR KIDS IN
DISCIPLINE THEIR KIDS, WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TH